news daily from science mission
scientist at the University of
California Riverside have now identified
a safe repellent that protects fruits
from drosophila Suzuki called butyl
anthranilate or VA a pleasant smelling
chemical compound produced naturally in
fruits in small amounts it provided
substantial protection at 2.5
concentration and complete protection at
ten percent and belong to the food
additive category approved by faa next
scientists develop a novel glucose
responsive insulin delivery device using
a painless micro needle array patch
containing hypoxia sensitive hyaluronic
acid-based vesicles the vesicles quickly
dissociate and release encapsulated in
saline under the local hypoxic
environment caused by the enzymatic
oxidation of glucose in the
hyperglycemic state this smart insulin
patch can regulate the blood glucose of
type 1 diabetic mice to achieve normal
levels with faster responsiveness for
more news visitors at www science
mission calm or science mission facebook
page thanks for what